Wo ist das grab von nofretete noch immer ist es nicht gefunden worden doch vor kurzem gab
es einen sehr spannenden hinweis in der grabkammer von
Tutanchamun da gab es seltsame echos und aus dem antiken ministerium hieß es
2015 dass man sich zu 90 prozent sicher sein dass dort neue kammern zu finden sein das grab von
Tutanchamun stiefmutter nofretete jetzt wurde es genauer untersucht jede ergebnisse weg zum science and fiction herzlich willkommen
Schon seit
3400 jahren ist der pharao tutanchamun tod und unter der erde vergraben seiner grabstätte wurde
1922 entdeckt und obwohl das schon lange her ist ist das tal der könige immer mal wieder eine schlagzeile wert zuletzt noch
Im sommer 2015 als ein britische archäologe verkündete dass es hinter einer grab des pharaos
Weitere räume gelbe linien strukturen nahm als hinweise und auf den aufnahmen der nördlichen und westlichen kalkstein wand der grabkammer
Wollte er vermehrte durchgängiger erkannt haben und nicole suisse setzte damals noch einen drauf denn in diesen wänden
sei, wohl die mumie von tutanchamuns stiefmutter
Nofretete zu finden nicht wenige witterten eine sensation es gab pressekonferenzen ohne ende
zusätzliche bodenuntersuchung eines radars spezialisten aus japan
machten weitere hoffnung denn auch seine messungen ergaben wohl hinweise darauf dass möglicherweise zwei weitere unbekannte räume
existieren könnten
langwierige und aufwendige radarmessungen eines forschungsteams
Im auftrag von national geographic sollten dann den endgültigen beweis liefern doch der blieb aus und das obwohl über stunden hinweg
50 einzel scans gemacht worden waren und das in zwei verschiedenen frequenzen doch das scannen
Im tal der könige schien sogar der sensation zu widersprechen dass damaligen forschungsteam war sich
Am ende sicher unentdeckte kann, man
Also, hohlräume müssten eine starke reflexion liefern und die blieb aus ein italienisches forschungsteam von der universität turin hat dann wohl
anomalien an grenzen an das fahren grab gefunden und zwar zwei stück links und rechts von
tutanchamuns grabkammer das hätten drohnen bilder gezeigt mit der sie die grabstätte gescannt hatten darauf sei eine sowohl
links als auch rechts von der grabkammer eine rote
Fläche zu sehen links etwas größer als recht auch die fläche unmittelbar neben der grabkammer weise
anomalien auf so der ehemalige antiken minister ägyptens mando
damit zitat wir können leider noch nicht
Sagen was diese anomalien bedeuten auf die frage ob es sich vielleicht tatsächlich um die grabkammer von königin nofretete
handelt sagt er nur weiter wir sind
wissenschaftler und keine spekulanten ja weitere untersuchungen bräuchten zeit und könnten dann gewissheit geben doch sei
der begriff der
anomalie ja dahinter lässt tatsächlich ein großes fragezeichen denn damit könnte theoretisch gesehen natürlich alles oder nichts gemeinsam einen hohlraum ein loch oder
Doch eine unbekannte kammer bislang sind diese ergebnisse des italienischen forschungsteams jedenfalls noch nicht in einem, wissenschaftlichen
Fachjournal zu wenden jetzt hat das team
Nachgelegt und die kammer weiter untersucht ja und das ergebnis ja das ist leider nicht
sensationell die polin untersuchungen schließen weitere grabkammern aus drei monate das team die grabkammern
durchleuchtet und ist auf nichts gestoßen zitat die hypothese hinsichtlich der existenz verborgenen kann man oder korridore
Die sich an tutanchamuns grab anschließen wird durch die gpa daten nicht gestützt so steht es, im ägyptischen
nachrichtenportal aram online
zu lesen dass aus dem abschlussbericht von francesco porcelli von der polytechnischen universität
Turin zitiert mit drei scan durchgänge wurden die ergebnisse jeweils überprüft
es gibt also keinen zweifel mehr die neueren untersuchungen mittels bodenradar gba waren nach
Den ersten untersuchungen geplant worden um hier eigentlich den fund zu bestätigen sie geht
Also weiter die suche nach dem grab von nofretete wenn er als erstes neues dazu
Zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp oder den anderen messaging wie instagram facebook oder?
telegramm dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
Täglich garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der redaktion von pixel mitmachen und mitbestimmen was hier wirklich passiert und zur begrüßung
Gibt es noch ein kleines goodie einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
stimmungslage vergessen hier geht es war damit auch dafür braucht die geheime kammer der jobs pyramide entdeckt ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran